ein Land im
Krieg fast zi Jahre sind seit dem
russischen Angriff
vergangen für die Menschen in der
Ukraine ein nicht enden wollender
Albtraum ein Leben voller nen die
bleiben werden überleben
[Musik]
ungewiss die ukrainische Gesellschaft
hat sich für den Kampf entschieden mit
allen
Konsequenzen
nur drei Flugstunden von uns entfernt
regieren die
Waffen wie sehen die Menschen hier ihre
Zukunft wie soll es
[Musik]
weitergehen
unsere Reise beginnt am 22 September V
einer polnischen Autobahn Richtung
ukrainischer
[Musik]
Grenze manchmal wollen sie dass nur der
Fahrer alle Pässe zeigt
abwarten in den kommenden Tagen will ich
mir ein Bild machen ins Gespräch kommen
mit den Menschen mehr fahren über das
Leben mit dem kriegsgeplagten
Land
unsere Reise beginnt im Westen und führt
uns über die Hauptstadt Kiev bis nach
Cherson und
Odessa die ukrainischen
Karpaten das Gebirge war schon immer ein
Rückzugsort wenn das Land angegriffen
wurde heute trifft man hier vor allem
Soldaten auf
Fronturlaub das Städchen truskz berühmt
für seine heil
an diesem friedlichen Ort sollen nun
auch kriegsmüde Soldaten wieder zu
Kräften
[Musik]
kommen ze Tage Erholungsurlaub gibt es
für jeden von ihnen auch Myron muss dann
zurück an die
Front wofür steht diese
[Musik]
Locke Kosaken durften sich nach ihrem
ersten Kampf mit dieser
stirnlock das war eine
Auszeichnung ich trage diese Locke um
ein Vorbild für die Jugend zu
sein sie waren in
bachmut nach meinem Urlaub geht's wieder
zurück und wie war es in bachmut
wirklich die Leute sollten das besser
nie erfahren nur Soldaten verstehen
das haben sie Russen
getötet ich bin doch kein Killer ich
verteidige nur die
Ukraine sind der Feind sie wissen dass
wir sie pederasten
nennen siehst du nicht siehst du
nicht und wie schwer ist es in ein
normales Leben
zurückzukehren na schwer viele in der
Ukraine denken der Krieg ist schon
vorbei weil sie nicht betroffen
sind aber es werden zunehmend alle
mobilisiert ich bin nur kurz hier ich
möchte diese Zeit meiner Familie
widmen ich arbeite als
militärpfahrer rund um die Uhr bin ich
bei meiner Brigade
Urlaub vom Krieg doch geht das noch
einfach mal den Horror kurz
abschalten warum sind sie Soldat
geworden meine Stadt wurde Anfang 2014
angegriffen ich muss doch meine Mama und
mein Papa
beschützen
überin wir reden mehr über uns als über
den
Krieg es bringt nichts über das Leid zu
sprechenpräche bringen nichts ich will
nicht drüber
reden im Westen der Ukraine weit weg vom
Kriegsgeschehen geht das Leben fast
seinen gewohnten Gang doch etwt
auf
fr tere Menschen aber kaum erwachsene
[Musik]
Männer auch die Kioskbesitzerin Oxana
vermisst ihre frühere
Kundschaft verkaufen sie im Krieg mehr
Alkohol als
sonst Giemen nokoholauf kann die
htewner
ist es schwer zu verstehen was im Land
gerade
passiert wir hier im Westen der Ukraine
haben unseren eigenen Standpunkt sie
wissen ja der Westen ist der Westen
vielleicht sind wir mehr Nationalisten
wussten sie dass im Westen die
allerfleißigsten Leute
sind vielleicht hatten die im Osten der
Ukraine höhere Löhne wir fuhren zum
Arbeiten ohnehin ins Ausland wenn du
Geld wolltest musstest du es im Ausland
verdienen so sollte es wieder sein aber
jetzt habe ich dazu nichts mehr zu
sagen Westen gegen Osten kommt einem
irgendwie bekannt vor wie sieht es in
den Ballungsräumen aus denken die
Menschen dort ähnlich
unversöhnlich unsere nächste Station
führt uns in die heimliche Hauptstadt
der Westukraine leviv das ehemalige
Lemberg wie durch ein Wunder haben im
Zweiten Weltkrieg weder die deutsche
noch die sowjetische Armee hier Häuser
zerstört jetzt fliegen russische Raketen
auch bis nach leeviv und haben bereits
mehrere Zivilisten
getötet hier begegne ich Jasko und Ilia
sie besuchen die Kadettenschule eine der
ältesten des Landes
die beiden sind gerade mal 16 und 17
Jahre alt ihr geht nicht an die Front
nein
nein in vi Jahren geht's zum
Stützpunkt dort kommen wir dann direkt
in eine
Führungsposition und was macht ihr
jetzt ich studiere
Psychologie warum habt ihr euch für die
Armee
entschieden weil ichen
will den Mens me
unstüen ich habe das freiwillig
entschieden und
du ich mache das schon Z
Jahre schon als Kind wollte ich Soldat
werden jetzt möchte ich die Ukraine
gegen den Feind
verteidigen zur Zeit gilt als relativ
sicher seit Kriegs die einwohnerzl auf
eineppe
millionesegen 50 000 Binnenflüchtlinge
aus den umkämpften Provinzen im Osten
haben hier seit dem Schutz gesucht viele
Leben in Wohnsiedlungen die zu Zeiten
der Sowjetunion entstanden sind auch
Familie stepanenko hofft hier auf einen
[Musik]
Neuanfang
natalus hinter ihr liegt die
traumatische Erfahrung vom 8 April
2022 gemeinsam mit 1us weiteren
Flüchtlingen wartet die Familie am
Bahnhof von kamatorsk auf ihre
Evakuierung als russische Raketen
einschlagen und alles
verändern Ärzte konnten ihr Leben retten
ihre unversehtheit aber nicht für die
Anfertigung der Prothesen wurden die
stepanenkos sogar in die USA geflogen
die Familie ist auf eigenen Wunsch in
die Ukraine
zurückgekehrt wo waren sie während des
Angriffs
wir waren im
Bahnhof ich bin mit jarik herumgelaufen
damit die Zeit halt schneller
vergeht ich erinnere mich dass Mama Jana
und Oma rausgegangen sind einz kaufen
ich bin beim Gepäck
geblieben wir sind aus dem Bahnhof raus
auf den
Bahnsteig wir hatten Hunger dann haben
wir ein Zelt mit Tee und Süßigkeiten
gesehen
plötzlich rief jemand
runter und dann ich guckte gerade zu
Jana wurde es plötzlich
dunkel wurde schwarz vor augen meine
Ohren
warenau ich erinnere mich nur wie ich
herumgewirbelt
wurde und dann lag ich schon am
Boden und das
war's überall liefen Leute
herum alle Fensterscheiben waren
kaputt die Leute hatten alle Blut im
Gesicht andere kamen angefahren und
machten
irgendwas als ich meine Augen wieder
aufmachte lagen da Tanja und Jana ich
sah auf ihre Beine da waren keine Schuhe
mehr und wie schwer ist es für ihre
Tochter mit dieser Situation
klarzukommen natürlich ist das schwer
aber das Leben muss ja
weitergehen am Bahnhof in leeviv setzen
wir unsere Reise fort ab jetzt kommen
wir dem Krieg immer näher ein
beklemmendes Gefühl das erste Mal in
meinem Leben dass ich ein Bahnhof
betrete und denke was wenn es jetzt
passiert und das ist das was Krieg
macht eigentlich ist rushau aber der Zug
nach Kiev bleibt halble
leer Richtung Hauptstadt unterwegs sind
außer uns vor allem fronturlauber die
zurückfahren im Zug treffe ich dann aber
noch Hanna sie ist
Handelsvertreterin haben sie seit
Kriegsbeginn jemals darüber nachgedacht
zu
fliehen ja ich habe die Ukraine am 24
Februar 2022
verlassen um 5 Uhr nachmittags hat die
Bombardierung begonnen und um 9 Uhr
abends bin ich mit meiner Familie aus
Kiev
geflohen schon drei Tage vor kriegsegn
sagte mein Mann er werde nicht mehr
Telefon
gehen der Krieg würde kommen und dann
würde er kämpfen
müssen ich konnte ihn gerade noch
überreden mich aus Kiev rauszubringen
das war mir
wichtig wir haben ein Kind und im
Bombenhagel wegzufahren ist sehr
gefährlich ich habe entschieden nach
Polen zu gehen weil meinater dortbt ein
JR ich bei
ih wollte ich wieder zurück nach Hause
um der Ukraine zu
helfen denn Heimat gibt es nur
einmal nach 5 Stunden fat wartet uns in
Kiev ungewohnte
Dunkelheit die nächste russische Rakete
könnte jederzeit
kommen die Stimmung ist gedrückt Bereich
des Bahnhofs blicken wir in viele
abgekämpfte
Gesichter etwas abseits komme ich dann
mit der jungen Programmiererin Xenia ins
Gespräch was denken sie über diesen
Krieg das alles ist
unfassbar mein Mann und ich waren in
harkiv als es
losging und das war wirklich sehr
beängstigend
wie kann man jetzt nicht die Hoffnung
verlieren ich weiß es nicht Krieg erlebe
ich nicht zum ersten
Mal ich habe in der Region Donet gewohnt
als es losging
2014 ja wir wissen wie sich Raketen
anhören und wir kennen das Geräusch der
Shahid drohen wirklich die Drohne genau
das ist okay also es ist
oh ich muss leider zum
[Musik]
Zug dass die Menschen hier so offen über
ihre Erlebnisse sprechen überrascht mich
viele bedanken sich bei uns wenn wir uns
als deutsches Team vorstellen anderthalb
Jahre Ausnahmesituation ohne
Unterstützung hätte die Ukraine kaum
eine
[Musik]
Chance am nächsten Tag fahren wir in
einen Vorort von
Kiev irpin wurde vor allem wegen seiner
Brücke
bekannt nach dem Einmarsch der Russen
wird sie vorsorglich vom ukrainischen
Militär
gesprengt in den Tagen danach entstehen
Bilder die um die Welt
gehen längst ist die Brücke von irpin
selbst zum Symbol des Krieges
geworden
hier treffe ich die Fotografin und
Aktivistin Soja Schuh seit der Besetzung
der Krim gibt sie Kriegsgefangenen eine
Stimme hier sehen Sie eine Narbe in Form
eines
Hakenkreuzes diese Wunde wurde einem
Ukrainer in Gefangenschaft
zugefügt das war 2014 in donetk 10 Tage
nach der sogenannten Wahl dem
sogenannten
Referendum
er hatte etwas pro-ukrainisches in
seinen sozialen Netzwerken
gepostet und das war die
Strafe er wurde in einen Keller gebracht
und dort 10 Stunden lang festgehalten
sie haben ihm zwei Fingernägel gewaltsam
entfernt und ein Hakenkreuz in den
Rücken geritzt sie wollten ihn
töten das passierte 2014 fotografiert
haben sie es 2019 also mindestens D
Jahre bevor dieser Krieg losging die
Welt hätte also bereits ahnen können was
hier vor sich
geht ich glaube die Menschen wollten es
nicht hören nicht wahrhaben was hier
passiert wir haben in Deutschland eine
große Diskussion darüber ob man die
Verhandlungen nicht wirklich
vorantreiben sollte um diesen Krieg
irgendwie zu
beenden
wenn wir verhandeln ihnen z.B
Territorien zurückgeben wird sie das
nicht aufhalten sie werden weiter
angreifen für uns ist das ein
existenzieller Krieg entweder wir
überleben oder nicht viele fragen warum
ich noch hier bin aber ich will nicht im
Ausland leben ich will in meiner Heimat
leben Heimat ein großes Wort in der
Ukraine
am Straßenrand bemerken wir einen Berg
aus zerstörten Autos vor dieser Kulisse
übt bckan mit seinem Freund mitro Trix
auf dem Motorrad bogdans Heimat hat der
Krieg besonders hart
getroffen wo lebst
Du ich komme aus
butcha ich bin schon immer
hier das heißt du hast die Russen kommen
sehen ich habe alles gesehen auch die
Leichen
wo hast du dich versteckt zu Hause ich
bin zu Hause geblieben die ganze
Zeit die haben nicht an e Tür geklopft
die kam nicht zu
euch vor unserem Haus steht so eine Art
Waldhütte deshalb haben sie uns nicht
entdeckt aber alle anderen Häuser in
meiner Straße haben sie
überfallen viele wurden
umgebracht aber zu uns kam sie nicht
und wenn sie gekommen wären hätten sie
meinen Hof nicht lebendig
verlassen hattet ihr Waffen Waffen
ja welche ein
Jagdgewehr und mein Vater trug unter der
Hose ein Messer am Bein wäre er gefangen
genommen worden dann hätte er sich
wehren können Sie erstechen
umbringen ich hatte auch ein Messer und
der me Vers das
Gewehr mit wem kannst du über all das
Sprechen mit niemanden ich mache das mit
mir selbst aus ich sehe das so es war
nicht so schlimm für mich Leichen und
zerfetzte Körper zu sehen ich bin da
resistent selbst in einen Gewehrlauf zu
sehen macht mir keine Angst mehr nichts
kann mich mehr
erschrecken
hast du vor irgendwann zum Militär zu
gehen Soldat zu
werden sobald ich 18 bin werde ich die
Russen
vernichten ich werde alles dafür tun
dass es sie auf dieser Erde nicht mehr
geben
wird aber das Leben wird nie mehr so
sein wie es war niemals alles ist
anders zerschossene abgebrannte von
Panzern überrollte
Autos Relikte des Massakers von butscha
mehr als 400 wehrlose Zivilisten von
russischen Truppen gefoltert und
hingerichtet butscha und irpin liegen
direkt nebeneinander zwei Vororte im
Nordwesten von Kiev überall Spuren der
Zerstörung allein in irpin wurden mehr
als 1000 Wohnhäuser
getroffen von heute auf morgen standen
unzählige Familien vor den Trümmern
ihrer
Existenz aber viele der geflohenen sind
zurückgekehrt der Wiederaufbau ist seit
anderthalb Jahren in vollem
Gang haben sie hier in diesem Haus
gewohnt ja das war alles unser Haus wir
haben es mit unserem ersparten selbst
gebaut wurde komplett
zerstört waren sie hier als das Haus
attackiert wurde
da waren wir schon weg ich war schwanger
und habe noch ein weiteres Kind darum
sind wir sofort geflohen hier gab es
viele Bomben flugzeugbomben es war
grauenvoll die
Hölle woher kommt diese russische
Brutalität ich weiß nicht man sagt ja
mit dem Verstand ist Russland nicht zu
begreifen ist es h ich kann es nicht
erklären nach dem Sieg bauen wir alles
wieder auf haben wir ja noch damit
werden wir arbeiten aber das wichtigste
ist erstmal der
[Musik]
Sieg bitte nicht kaputt machen steht auf
diesem
Garagentor Perspektiven über den
nächsten Tag hinaus nicht wirklich
wichtig dieser Durchhaltewille
beeindruckt uns auf der gesamten
Reise Sie von
hier waren sie an der Front
inachm wie lange waren sie dort wir
kämpfen noch morgen geht's zurück und
wie lange sind Sie schon an der
Front am 24 Februar 2022 ging es los wir
liefen hier beüber die Brücke auf die
andere Seite von
IRP dann kam ich in andere kampfregionen
ich war
überall wie haben sie die Zeit der
Besatzung hier erlebt wie war
das wir haben den Stab bis zuletzt
verteidigt dann haben sie die Stadt
erobert und wir mussten
abziehen unsere Leute über den Fluss
bringen das heißt die Russen waren hier
überall ja waren
sie ich war zuletzt am 14 März
hier da hab ich eine Frau aus einem
Keller
gerettet die Geschosse
geflogen drohen griffen uns
an dort haben sich noch unsere Jungs
verteidigt in einem Hof stand ein
Panzer und auf dem Nachbargrundstück
wohnten
wir dann wurde mein Vater
erschossen ja erst die Hände gefesselt
dann
erschossen
[Musik]
gestern haben wir zwei Jungen getroffen
16 und 18 Jahre alt sehr jung sie wollen
unbedingt zum Militär gehen und
kämpfen was denken sie über solche
jungen
Männer
nicht wenn dieser Krieg endet W dieser
Krieg enden wird es dann wieder ein
normales Leben
geben wird
es viele werden dann ohne Arme oder
Beine sein aber wir werden das Überleben
ich fahre jetzt wieder an die Front
später nach Ivano frankissk dort stellen
Amerikaner mein Gesicht durch plastische
Chirurgie wiederher auch die Zähne
werden gemacht und die
[Musik]
Finger e Ina dutzende Leichen lagen hier
einige mit gefesselten Händen andere mit
schusswund im Kopf ich stehe heute auf
derselben Straße die Häuser sehen fast
aus wie früher aber die Menschen die
hier wohnen sind nicht mehr
[Musik]
dieselben die meisten Opfer des
Massakers liegen hier begraben auf dem
Friedhof von butscha ein unheilvoller
[Musik]
Ort Sergei kommt aus Bucha und hat das
Massaker mit viel Glück überlebt schon
während der russischen Besatzung hat er
angefangen die Leichen zu bergen von
Beruf ist er eigentlich
Rettungssanitäter der Krieg hat ihn zum
Totengräber und Bestatter
gemacht hier liegen die Toten aus
butscha ihre Angehörigen konnten zu den
Beerdigungen
kommen dahinten liegen unbekannte die
wir aus dem Massengrab geborgen haben es
gab keine Verwandten die sie
identifizieren konnten darum stehen die
Nummern der DNA Tests auf den
Gräbern sie bestatten hier die Menschen
aus den
Massengräber habe ich die Toten aus den
Massengräbern eingesammelt und hier
beerdigt immer wieder wurde ich von den
Russen
bedroht sie hielt mir ein
Maschinengewehr an den Kopf und drohten
mich zu erschießen obwohl auf meinem LKW
die Leichen lagen war mir so
egal einer sagte mir z.B stell Dich an
die Wand aber ich habe ihn zum Teufel
geschickt er jetzt begreif ich Gott auf
mich aufgep
hat
[Musik]
was haben die gesagt warum waren die
hier wir haben sie mehr als einmal
gefragt was wollt ihr hier wir sagten
sie bringen den Frieden ich antwortete
welchen Frieden warum liegen all diese
Menschen auf dem Friedhof warum habt ihr
sie mit msern
beschossen Jungs bei uns in der Ukraine
ist alles gut was wollt ihr
hier
und mancher Russe wusste wovon ich rede
und antwortete glaubst du ich weiß nicht
dass eure Regierung euch verarscht wie
unsere uns glaubst du ich will nicht
meine Frau und Kinder Wiedersehen sie
wussten dass sie nicht mehr Leben
zurückkehren
werden vor kurzem habe ich einen toten
Russen
ausgegraben ich hatte ih Massengrab
beerdigt aber
separat dann seine Angehörigen in
Russland über den DNA-Test gefunden ich
habe ihn wieder ausgegraben und seine
Leiche wurde für einen unserer Toten
ausgetauscht wir besuchen den Ort an dem
lebendige Soldaten um ihre Zukunft
fürchten das offiziell einzige Lager der
Ukraine für russische Kriegsgefangene es
müssen tausende sein ein seltener
Einblick in eine düstere
Welt die genaue Lage des Camps ist
geheim warum sich die Gefängnistore für
uns öffnen
unklar die Ukrainer präsentieren der
Welt ihre Gefangenen um Druck aufzubauen
denn der Austausch stockt seit
Monaten die Interviews führen wir ohne
ukrainische Aufsicht und wir filmen und
befragen nur die Männer die vorher
ausdrücklich zugestimmt
haben was haben sie ihn erzählt warum
sollten Sie in diesen
Krieg es wurden gar keine Gründe
genannt
warum wer weiß das
schon ihre Frage ist fals es ist kein
Krieg wir haben der russischen
Bevölkerung und Don bas
geholfen es gab eine Mobilmachung ich
bin zur Arbeit gekommen und erhielt dort
meinen Einberufungsbescheid und das
war's ich bin maschinengewehrchütze ich
habe aber auf niemanden geschossen hätte
es ein Angriff gegeben dann ja aber Gott
sei Dank gab es
kein ich habe gedacht dass ich in der
Armee schneller zu Geld komme aber so
war es nicht nein getötet habe ich nicht
nicht ein einziges mal
ehrlich Gott sei Dank klebt kein Blut an
meinen
Händen wir sind schon so lange hier ich
will nur nach
Hause denken sie manchmal wir wurden
verraten und
belogen wir haben nicht geglaubt dass es
Krieg geben wird
es gibt verschiedene Wahrheiten für mich
gilt nur diese
eine für viele hier ist der Knast nichts
Neues sie kommen direkt aus russischen
Gefängnissen wurden für den Krieg mit
großen Versprechungen
geködert warum die Ukraine gekommen um
zu kämpfen ich war im Gefängnis und
Präsident Putin versprach uns dass wir
begnadigt werden wenn wir
kämpfen und dass es gutes Geld dafür
gibt und warum haben sie
gesessen wegen
Mord hat man sie einfach so losgeschickt
wo haben sie
gekämpft wir hatten vorher nicht mal
Training oder Schießübung nichts es ging
direkt an die Front in den
Einsatz als wir dann bombardiert wurden
sind alle
abgehauen nur wir Häftlinge konnten
nicht fliehen denn hinter der Frontlinie
gab es sperreinheiten die sofort auf uns
geschossen
hätten ich sehe das so wir knack sind
kanonfutter wir werden einfach
reingeworfen um an der Front in
stückissen zu
werden was denken sie inzwischen über
diesen Krieg ich weiß nicht was ich von
der Politik halten soll aber das ist
alles natürlich nicht richtig
Essensausgabe etwas Abwechslung im
Gefängnisalltag diese russischen Männer
sind beides Täter und
Opfer wie sind sie hier
gelandet ich hatte mich kam chatka
gemeldet eigentlich nur für einen Job in
Donet sie sagten mir dass ich gutes Geld
verdienen
würde ich sollte dort Wohnungen wieder
aufbauen und
renovieren und jetzt hocke ich hier als
Kriegsgefangener Rekrutierung mit allen
Mitteln so wie jeevgeni ging es wohl
vielen
nach zwei Monaten auf der Baustelle
wurde unsere Gruppe mitten am Tag
abgeholt und dann ging es sofort an die
Front zum Sturmangriff rein in den
Fleischwolf von allen vier Seiten wurde
auf uns gefeuert von meiner Einheit
haben vielleicht elf überlebt auch die
anderen Soldaten sind
gefallen wahrscheinlich liegen ihre
Leichen noch immer
dort fühlen sie sich Ben von russischen
Politikern von
Putin natürlich was glauben Sie denn wie
ich mich sonst fühlen soll wir wurden
einfach in den Kampf
hineingeworfen wir wurden einfach in den
Kampf hineingeworfen und von unseren und
euren
abglichesitärisches Training man uns in
denischwoli wissen jetzt überhaupt nicht
mehr wer wir sind keine Ahnung was aus
uns wird wenn wir wieder in Russland
sind was passiert daheim in Russland
während die Männer im Gefängnis
festsitzen zweimal im Monat dürfen sie
für 5 Minuten nach Hause
telefonieren hallo
und es ist nicht nur die schlechte
Verbindung die ihn dabei zu schaffen
macht so klingen viele dieser
telefonategeni wen haben Sie heute
angerufen ihre
Frau meine
Schwester ich habe sie lange nicht mehr
gehört ich habe nur noch sie meine
Mutter und meine Oma
sonst niemanden mehr und jetzt bin ich
hier
gelandet ich nütze der Familie gar
nichts ich will
nicht jetzt warten wir Gefangenen darauf
dass wir ausgetauscht werden aber unsere
Regierung soll ja die Verhandlungen
gestoppt haben sie haben alles
eingefroren
im ukrainischen Hauptquartier für
Gefangenen Austausch in Kiev wird das
ganze Elend des Krieges
greifbar hierher kommen Angehörige von
vermissten Soldaten die auf ein
Lebenszeichen hoffen und oft bitter
enttäuscht
werden die Verwandten wollen nichtauben
der üereinstimmung vorliegt sie können
es einfach nicht fassen dass Ihr
Angehöriger nachweislich tot ist deshalb
fragen Sie immer wieder nach einer
erneuten
D das Vertrauen in die russische Seite
geht gegen
[Musik]
Null wie würden Sie diese russische
Kultur
beschreiben ich würde sie als Kultur des
Todes bezeichnen in der Geschichte russ
sieht man dass die Untertanen ihr Leben
für ihre Herrscher Opfern
mussten und das war für sie völlig
normal wer an die Front geht und für
Russland stirbt ist in der Heimat ein
Held seit dem Tod von jeevgeni
prigoschin sehen wir viele russische
Sträflinge im Krieg die in den
sogenannten sturmz Bataillonen kämpfen
sie wurden direkt aus russischen
Gefängnissen rekrutiert Welle für Welle
stürmen sie unsere Schützengräben sie
sind lediglich
Kanonenfutter
die Personen die sich in unseren
Kriegsgefangenen Lagern befinden hatten
Glück denn nur einer von 100 russischen
Soldaten überlebt und landet
hier und wie viele Leute fehlen ihnen
wie viele ukrainische
Soldaten diese Frage beantworten wir
nicht weil Russland nicht alle
Kriegsgefangenen offiziell
bestätigt deshalb sind viele ukrainische
Soldaten als vermisst registriert
und können Sie sie finden manchmal
ja und natürlich nutzt Russland die Not
der Familien und deren
Hoffnung die Kriegsgefangenen doch noch
zu finden
ukrainische Kriegsgefangene werden
gezwungen ihre Angehörigen anzurufen und
ihnen z.B zu sagen Mama ich lebe
Russland würde mich gehen lassen aber
die Ukraine tut nichts
dafür um die Gesellschaft zu
destabilisieren
ja natürlich das ist jetzt das Hauptziel
Russlands unsere ukrainische
Gesellschaft zu
schwächen denn an der Front erreichen
sie
nichts dass die Russen nicht
unbezwingbar sind sollen diese
erbeuteten Panzer auf dem Kiever
michaelsplatz zeigen
[Musik]
21 Monate dauert der Krieg bereits was
macht das mit der Gesellschaft den
Menschen den
Familien